it's a tremendous story uh is your first
season of saturday night live and
you
i guess on the way home or during that
period of time
you saw something on a car that you
liked
in a parking lot or something no no no
so i stole some hubcaps yeah that's
right
[Applause]
that's yeah but it's not like i what
happened was i used to have to take the
train
into the city when my first year snl i
would take the long island railroad to
the city and when i came and i would
park in freeport and i had a car with
nice hubcaps and i came back one night
and my hubcaps were gone you know and i
took somebody else's healthcare
but it's but i was on tv already that
was still popping up
[Music]
[Applause]
[Laughter]
first i like to thank um
eddie pull it up like i was working for
him
and i started to do it too yes mike wait
what am i doing
how old are you now i'm 33. no you're
that old well you look great you look
like you're 23. well thank you
how old are you i am 47. let's see you
look 29.
so what do you do to work out do you
have like the personal trainer gig you
know my dad used to be a professional
boxer so we have so it was mine really
my dad what weight class my dad was the
lightweight really yeah that was
lightweight too really i remember my dad
just kicked the hell out of your dad
[Applause]
my dad fought underneath the bronx flash
well if your dad was that tough then you
should be able to bust my ass
[Applause]
normally i don't like to kick the guests
around but you know
sometimes it is necessary
stay tuned for more of the sami davis
junior tribute honoring the one
heavyweight i would never dare step into
the ring with sammy you're a true
undefeated champ
wait
i think mike can do a little better than
that mike
okay i'm gonna i'm gonna attempt to read
this this may be disastrous
okay
stay tuned for more of the sammy davis
jr trivia honoring the one heavyweight i
would never dare step into the ring with
sammy you are truly the undefeated
champion
[Applause]
the producers of the show the producers
of the show was hoping you'd have a
little more feeling more mike you know a
little bit more mike tyson you know more
mike tysonism like like hello ladies and
gentlemen sammy and i was like
it's just a lot of cool old people in
the old days i met jerry lewis i met
jule brynner
really had he been on he was no i met
him at studio 54 when i was like 19.
you'll yield brenner's in studio 54.
yeah and even if he was having a party
afterwards eddie would you like to come
to my house to party
it's surreal
and that's the real three times did you
go to the party no i didn't well he was
like six that was like nineteen i think
oh man it's part of this yeah
am i wrong did i have eddie murphy doll
there was no eddie murphy doll there was
never an eddie murphy dog no but i was
approached for stuff like that when i
was they would come and say hey mr dog
the most ridiculous one was eddie murphy
chocolate
it made the chocolate drink you put your
chocolate in stir it up your face on it
editor murphy chocolate
man hey daddy chocolate drink like we
had actually had a meeting and people
had drawn stuff up and stuff you see
eddie murphy chocolate would be very
popular in this region
first time i met randy dangerfield that
was uh
in florida to come it was the first
comedian that i met that was famous and
i was about 17 he came and he bumped me
at this club i was getting ready to go
and said dangerfield's here
and i was like oh no so you went up yeah
i got no respect killed it blew the
whole place
then i had to go up after him i did my
show i had a good set and i went up
after i said so it's a danger feeling
what you're thinking sir we're going to
go cause back to mac was real dirt
dirtier than it was five years when i
was 17. whoo forget about it your act
was dirtier when you were 17. oh much
dirtier much dirty like the audience
would sit there look
and afterwards i went up to dangerfield
says what you think and he said we're
gonna go with all of that and then i saw
him again maybe like
seven years later like after saturday
night live and after the movies no he
might not even remember this in a in a
bathroom in caesar's palace well and
i'm at the urinal and uh dangerfield
walks up and he looks over at me and he
just goes who knew
seven years later
michael jackson had his chimps when he
would go to his house that bubbles chimp
when he got a certain age yeah you
couldn't put bubbles yeah bubbles in the
cage
don't go near him
don't go over there
do you go to his house yeah a few times
then the chimp would be ah i'm going
crazy is that's bubble they said yes
don't go near the cage
really i thought bubbles was
don't go over there how old are your
kids like are your kids going into show
business i have i have eight kids and my
kids range yes
eddie
now i know why you haven't been here in
13 years
and they go from age 3 to
21 20. oh eddie
are you all right yeah
he's a very very fertile man i guess
very very dense sperm okay
that's too much
[Music]
because tracy told me that you he went
to your house and you made him
as he said over and over again to me
ballpark franks
he said i went over there he made me
pranks more pop french
[Applause]
that's why i'ma always be cool with it
because she may be them franks
and when i was young they used to call
me fat murphy
that's when he told me that muhammad
how do you feel about boxing today has
it changed since your reign
it's been a long time since i've done
this
people use the things your favorites are
with me i can't wait to show everybody
come back and see how the old cell's
over so i couldn't do it no more
fight mike tyson i'm sure if i'm still
great and beat everybody in the morning
doing my face still pretty
what would you do what what were your
activities what were you into out here
yeah just the basic stuff you know back
then we used to play in the street and
play skelly and
hot peas and butter
[Laughter]
did they still play hot peas and butter
did y'all play no we didn't play hot
pete what is hot piece and you would
take a take like a belt and you would
like hide it somewhere and everybody
would try to look for it when they get
closer you go oh you're getting hot
you're getting hot and then when they
find it there's hot peas and butter and
they could whip you on them
now i know why we didn't play it yeah
very very violent nbc mean you know i'ma
let the cat out the bat nbc means no
blacks or colors that's what it means
that's why the black people gonna start
their own network the abn network the
all black network nah i was like oh he's
not coming and then it was like hey let
eddie host you know what made them mad
uh i didn't say live from new york it's
saturday night i said live from new york
it's the eddie murphy show
oh my god
did y'all make bill give his back
no because i know there was a big outcry
from people that was trying to get bill
to give his trophies back
you know you that when they want you to
give your trophies back
[Applause]
trophy back too
he should do one show we just come out
and just talk crazy now
i would like to talk to
some of the people
who feel
that i should give back my
toys
just because
you
may have heard
recently that i allegedly put the pill
into people's chocolate
i wish somebody would come up to my
house talking about give up the trophy
because you put the pill in the paper
chocolate you get
cause i'm not giving back
and who
who is
hannibal barris
hannibal
first of all
hannibal is a caveman's name
and you're going to just come on out and
pull pushed over the apple cart that had
if i ever see
or meet this hannibal embarrassing
person
i am going to try to kill this [ __ ]
what do you hate most about show
business
i don't hate anything about show
business i don't hate it i love what i
do and i love this business i love it
all if i wasn't doing this i'd be
somewhere like this pull a car
you won't cop on the wax with that
wait very much
when you're in the position
[Music]
when you're in there
what time tony do
that's time for my break man
i got to go to dentist
my two come out again